- I know obviously when the
Jordan Poole video came out, there was
a lot of chatter about that video.
But when you watch that video,
how do you feel about yourself?
- Well, when I watched the video—
when that video first came out,
I watched that video...
all day.
Go to it. Watch it.
Watch it over and over again.
Leave it. Go do something else.
Come back to the video.
Watch it again.
Because that video had me form
an opinion about myself.
And I was sitting there,
and as someone who was involved
in the incident, I totally forgot
in watching the video
everything that went on.
Because in the video, you watch an audioless
video, you watch a three-
second clip of me walking up,
and I swing, and, like, that's what you see.
That video was put out there like that
to portray me
the exact way it did.
Does that mean I was not wrong in
what I did?
No. That does not mean
that. One hundred percent was the wrong reaction.
- Mmhmm.
- But in everything,
there's also a full story.
I don't care to share my story.
One day I will.
It ain't the time nor the place,
nor do I care to share it.
Care more about figuring this team out
and trying to win.
But one day I will cuz
there's always a time.
But what I
figured out
in watching that video for all day is, like,
“Damn, this is,
this actually was
what this was meant to do.” Like,
this was meant to form an opinion about me
and not give another side to it.
Like, not even allow another opinion
to be formed.
This video was put out just like this—
no audio.
If we've got this video,
we got the whole practice, right?
Like, we got everything, right?
- Mmhmm.
- All you see is, what, five seconds?
And so what I had to do is No. 1, and—
because, like, once that released,
I'm experiencing so many emotions, right?
Like, I'm upset.
Like, how the hell does this get released?
I'm, like,
going through hell
because you're,
I mean,
just at the sole discretion
of public opinion.
And on the flip side of that,
also dealing with my team,
whose sentiments
also changed once the video came out.
So, here you are, here I am
in a situation where
everybody was there, everyone attended,
whatever was gonna be was gonna be.
And then the video comes out,
and everything changes.
And so now I'm like, “Wow.”
But that's what this was intended to do.
That's why this was released this way.
And so in going through every emotion
and experiencing
all the different emotions
that I was experiencing, in order
for me
to even start to unpack this whole thing,
I have to look at it
from every point of view.
Like, I can't just go in like, “Well,
this is the point of view
I'm gonna look at it from and that’s it.”
Like, you come out very shortsighted.
Like, you come out with
not all the facts. You come out with
not a complete
understanding because you didn't
look at a complete picture.
And so
I had to start looking at this thing
from, like, so many different viewpoints
and trusting different people’s viewpoints
that I trust, you know,
trusting some people’s viewpoints
that I don't trust, like, and just really using
that to kind of dissect
and unpack this whole thing.
And in doing
that,
it really led me to some different spaces.
But like I said, one of those spaces being
this was put out like this
to form that opinion on me
that it did.
- So, just a clarifying question
cuz I'm curious.
And I can't tell
if this is what you're really insinuating, and
I don't want to be wrong.
The video coming out
you feel like was, like,
a calculated thing
for the video to come out.
- One hundred percent.
- OK.
- You ain't never seen another video
from my practice
That camera gotta
be on every day, right?
Or was it just on that day, in that moment,
for those five seconds?
You ain’t see one of our plays draw—
that we drawn up in practice
coming out from those videos.
You ain't seen anything else
coming out from practicing those videos.
So, it's 100 percent calculated.
Who was it calculated by?
I don't know.
I would still love to know that answer.
I still don't have an answer
on how the video got released.
Not sure I will ever get an answer.
To be honest with you,
I'm not even in search of an answer.
I would love to know, but I ain't chasing
after it. For what? It's a waste of my time.
What happened, happened.
I accepted my responsibility in it.
And once I accepted,
once I accepted my responsibility,
then I started to move forward.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, I accepted my responsibility. I knew I was wrong.
I apologized to those
that I needed to apologize to.
And now it's time to do the work
and move forward.
And so, in saying that, I'm
not gonna spend a bunch of time going
to try to figure out—
- Right.
- Who released it,
because it’s behind me, you know?
And I want it to stay behind me.
I don't wanna put that back
in front of me. And so, um,
but it's 100 percent a calculated thing
by whoever released it or
whoever was behind it. It’s 100 percent calculated.
I wish I knew the answer of who
it was calculated by.
- Mmhmm.
- But it's definitely calculated.
- So, with you—and I knowobviously
I’ve listened to your podcast talking about it.
I saw the piece you did on TNT and, like,
taking the responsibility of being wrong
in the video. That what you did,
you know, and I honestly
don't really know the question to ask
because we don't know what happened,
you know?
And that's not a thing you wanna share,
and that's totally fine.
But with the information
that we have presented to us
from what we saw in the video,
do you think that you all have been able
to be in this space to move forward?
Do you think that you have shown to Jordan,
based on what we have seen,
that you are sorry, that you want to move
forward, that it can be put behind you?
- Ah...
We go to work every day together.
Our lockers are right next to each other.
That never changed.
We ride the same buses together.
We change in the same locker room
on the road together. We—
none of that has changed.
Did it change our relationship?
Of course! Absolutely.
That's still a work in progress.
I will always be willing to continue
to do that work
because I was wrong.
- Mmhmm.
- And so, in saying all of that,
yes. Like,
definitely allowed to move forward.
And we have moved forward,
and it's been just fine.
But is it different? One hundred percent.
And not that
I expected it to be the same, right?
Like, if I had to say back then, like,
“Oh, I think this would go like this,”
or, “I think it'll go like that,”
I can't say it's went very different
or it's been very far off from the way
I thought it would go.
- Mmhmm.
- I think it's been
pretty close
to the way that I thought it would go.
But as far as, like, us moving forward,
we've definitely moved forward.
And...and I see improvements
day by day, week by week,
month by month,
I see improvements.
- That's good.
- And that's all you can ask for,
you know?
I don't expect him to come out
and be like, “Man,
I wanna come hang with you
off the court!”
And, like, I don’t expect that. Like, I'm
not, I'm not a fool.
Like, I grew up in Saginaw,
Michigan. Like, I’ve been in fights before.
Like, been in this situation before. I know how
you come out of those situations.
Like,
it's not what I expected.
- Mmhmm.
- So, in saying
that, it's
kinda what I expected it to be,
but it's a
constant work in progress
because it's very important
to the makeup of our team,
to the success of our team.
- Mmhmm.
- And so, I continue to do the work.